aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
alors comme je suis censé parler des
régions j'ai quand même en dire deux
mots
la vérité Jean-Pierre c'est que lorsque
tu as prévu les régions lorsque on a mis
en place un certain nombre de choses les
régions étaient faites pour aider pour
aider les collectivités pour faire en
sorte d'être des collectivités de
d'investissement
et en 1998 lorsque la gauche prend un
certain nombre de régions 60% des
crédits vont à l'investissement
seulement 40% ou fonctionnement c'est
aujourd'hui l'inverse pourquoi parce que
les régions socialistes ont augmenté
l'impôt 60% en moyenne dans l'ensemble
du pays ont augmenté les personnels 70%
en moyenne dans l'ensemble des régions
ont augmenté les subventions et on a
fait de la dilution on a fait du
clientélisme aujourd'hui par exemple la
seule région Île-de-France
subventionne 3500 associations ça n'est
pas dans l'objectif de la région mais
c'est en réalité dans le clientélisme
qui fait les voix et puisqu'on m'a
demandé de citer quelques cas un peu
particuliers dans ma belle région
d'Île-de-France je vais vous dire par
exemple j'ai des souvenirs la joie
Île-de-France a subventionné le festival
off
des musiques nomades à Nouakchott
quoi
si vous voyez pas le lien entre l'île de
France et la Mauritanie c'est que vous
avez un problème géographique
et quand je dis au président Huchon à
l'époque je ne comprends pas pourquoi
est-ce qu'on paye le festival Off des
musiques nomades à Nouakchott il me
répond mais vous n'avez pas vu il y a
des mulets qui se promènent dans le
wakshot et sur ces mulets et bien il y a
le logo de la région Île-de-France
et là
je ne sais pas
combien de mauritaniens étaient capables
de reconnaître le logo de la région
Île-de-France mais je sais combien les
Franciliens l'ont payé
de la même manière sous prétexte de dire
on a tout pouvoir on fait de la
coopération internationale alors de
temps en temps il y a des actions
efficaces et de temps en temps par
exemple cette belle région
d'Île-de-France elle a payé la création
la construction du musée Salvador
Allende à Santiago du Chili
et on a mis plus d'argent nous régions
Île-de-France que la ville de Santiago
elle-même pourquoi est-ce que c'est à
nous de construire un musée Salvador
Allende après on a fait un certain
nombre de choses d'ailleurs au Chili
dans la foulée de la même manière on a
payé de manière inconsidérée alors je
passe sur les folies mes clientes parce
que les écolos disent nous on veut ça
parce que les communistes d'isabet nous
on veut ça parce que les sociétés nous
on veut ça et le résultat on finance on
finance on finance aujourd'hui la région
Île-de-France sur un budget de 6
milliards d'euros indépendamment de 7
milliards de transport sur 6 milliards
d'euros verse un milliard d'euros tout
confondu à plein d'associations qui
n'ont rien à voir avec l'action
régionale et ce milliard d'euros bah
c'est vaut 60% de fiscalité
supplémentaires
et donc dans la pratique il faut revenir
il faut revenir en la dit redit il faut
revenir à une gestion plus efficace on
n'est pas là en région Île-de-France et
j'espère bien que Valérie Pécresse va
largement gagner et remettre de l'or
dans la maison il faut remettre de l'or
dans la maison ça peut pas ça peut pas
continuer et quand je vois et quand je
vois que le candidat Barcelone n'a rien
n'a proposé n'a rien à dire sur la
gestion et bien on est inquiet sur
l'avenir si malheureusement il devait
gagner et ce ne sera pas le cas parce
que les Franciliens sont bien conscients
que leur vrai problème c'est les
transports publics c'est pas le fait que
la Région organise publie face en sorte
de financer tous les ans un festival
éthicole fashion
on n'est pas là non plus pour faire en
sorte de dépenser sans compter et si
vous voulez le drame véritable c'est que
quand Jean-Pierre quand d'autres ont mis
un peu sur les fondements l'ensemble des
législations sur les régions c'était
prévu pour faire des lycées faire des
transports publics faire de
l'apprentissage favoriser l'emploi et
des entreprises et c'est devenu un
gigantesque système clientéliste qui en
réalité ne fonctionne pas augmente les
impôts augmente considérablement la
dette et aujourd'hui j'arrêterai là
Jean-Pierre il faut arrêter il faut
arrêter on n'est pas là et on ne peut
plus et on a plus les moyens de faire en
sorte que vous soyez seulement les
payeurs des folies socialistes des
folies clientéliste de ces régions nous
avons besoin de région efficaces nous ne
sommes pas là pour faire en sorte que
ces gens aient des clientèles des soucis
des éléments qui leur payent en
permanence leurs secteur alors voilà
demain Pécresse ici tous nos candidats
ailleurs doivent remettre de l'ordre
dans les maisons région sinon je le dis
sincèrement et pourtant je suis plutôt
régionaliste je pense que les régions
seront appelées à disparaître parce
qu'elles seront l'étape l'intermédiaire
l'étage institutionnel en trop par
rapport à des institutions qui
fonctionnent non nous ne sommes pas là
pour des systèmes clientéliste votez
pour nos candidats c'est voter pour la
raison pour la rigueur pour la bonne
gestion